you talk about this question this
fascinating question what does it take
for a country to prosper
what does it take for contrary to
prosper you see many countries in the
world that really struggle and many that
flourish and it's not always obvious why
because some have natural resources some
don't
some
have uh Wars some don't some have
uh sort of authoritarian regimes some
don't and some have democracies and all
that kind of stuff so you the Dynamics
aren't exactly obvious is there is there
commonalities is there
um fundamental ideas that result in a
prosperity of a Nation today I can
confidently say yes
despite all the differences that you
talked about and I think then this is
where it becomes very important
that we are very clear about the
question you asked me
you said what does it take to make a
country prosperous so I'm just going to
stick to Prosperity because Prosperity
doesn't necessarily mean sometimes
doesn't has nothing to do with maybe how
you
um conduct yourself otherwise socially
speaking right so you can be prosperous
and still when it comes to your family
laws all the way you approach the other
aspects of your life maybe you're
running a very communist lifestyle
or during a very afford another a very
liberal you know Society so for me when
we talk about Prosperity I just want to
make sure that we're clear on that
because some people might save it might
be somewhere and be like well you
because I know what I'm going to talk to
you about next and some people are going
to sit there and be like well China is
not like that or you know uh even um
Dubai is not like that
um no so what I'm talking about is this
thing and that's what I love about this
if we just stick to the word prosperity
to me I see Prosperity is this it's like
economically speaking what are we going
to be to be a prosperous Nation meaning
we are a middle to high income Nation
I'm not talking about
what are the rights of your women to to
vote or can people live like this or
um I'm not talking about any economic
fundamentally economic yes Prosperity
because I think it's that distinction is
very important because over the years
I've seen people push back on all types
of things and I'm and it occurred to me
that that's what the misunderstanding
was there so if we're going to talk
about prosperity
making sure that the country can make
money so that they can take care of its
needs and the needs of its citizens
um then what I have come to find is that
at the root of that is going to be what
we call economic freedom and what I call
the toolkit of the entrepreneur in that
you can put the rule of law you can put
the concept of clear and transferable
property rights
um economic freedom is at all the levels
that which will allow entrepreneurs
and business people
to create value
and create value entrepreneurially we're
not talking about when seeking or
anything like that it's like you found a
pie to be this big and you make it this
big so that's what we're talking about
create value create value yes
so when it comes to that we have found
that um
whoever you're looking at two countries
that start out the same we're talking
the same people East Germany West
Germany
South Korea North Korea
very similar people to start with right
but yet radical outcomes
I know that today Germany is United but
we're talking about back in the days
when you had East and Western block
same people very different outcomes like
I said South Korea
um North Korea and so on and so forth
and at the same time very different
nations
Dubai compared to
Singapore or to England
very different yet
the same outcome so it seems to me like
whenever we're looking at Prosperity if
a nation is prosperous
regardless of whatever other Shenanigans
they might be running whatever other
operating software they might be running
for anything that's not related to
business
if on the business side
they are
proponents of a free market or at least
a base
level of free markets we know that such
countries will create Prosperity so what
are the aspects of the operating systems
that lead to Singapore and and to South
Korea and all that kind of stuff so can
you speak the different elements that
enable the toolkit for entrepreneurs
sure sure
and maybe here
let me just maybe illustrate it with my
own story and then I can take you back
tell us your story oh no who are you
it's just because it started with me
coming here you shouldn't be the robot
anything and now it looks like I'm not
even only sorry for trouble and then
you're like tell people and then no no
but so this is where this question even
when you ask me how are some some
country how do some countries become
prosperous
that question Lex I had it when I was
seven or so that's when my family
moved me to um from Senegal for the
first time of my life I left my country
I left my continent and I was headed to
Europe to go join my people my my family
my parents who were there as economic
migrants my parents had migrated for a
better life
as so many people have to
so many people have to coming from
poorer places coming for low-income
countries so you saw the difference yes
between the two places I
how else would you call it here you are
in Senegal minding your own business
causing tons of trouble everywhere you
know just being a business
being a free-range kid but I was yeah so
you were always a troublemaker and I
just now always okay okay life would it
be fun without you and of course I agree
making behind you desperately trying to
keep it together I know you are but with
me I'm gonna
just yeah so so you saw the difference
right I saw a bit different I'm walking
in here
back home and I tell people the story
because to me it's a defining story
back home to take a shower it's a it
takes time
grandma has to you know make the
charcoal catch on a little stove like
you use at you know when you go camping
and when she puts a pot of water on it
it boils she takes it puts it in a
bigger bucket mixes it with some colder
water then we put a little pot in it and
a stronger member of the family has to
drag it to the shower and then there
finally I can proceed to take my shower
here I'm in Germany in the middle of the
winter and my mom's like Oh my God time
for your shower I'm like I'm I'm not
getting naked where's the bottles
whoever wins the boys a bucket of hot
water she's like oh you silly come on
just jump in and I jump in the shower
turn the buttons the water is coming
down temperature I wanna play
are you kidding me it's so amazing I've
been cheated out of life my whole life
yeah so that's what happened and then I
then and then I'm like oh and all of
these roads they're paved roads are like
back home everything is like Sandy and
you know my feet are always Ash I always
have to wash off when I back when I go
back home and your shoes get ruined most
of the time
and it started there and then I had this
question and it was just like wow how
come they have this and we don't
so I was not being like Oh you know how
come they have all of his money oh I was
not it was just like how come and I
think what I was alluding to was how
come life is so easy here it's not an
easy not in a negative sense in a
beautiful sense sometimes I get uh you
know just having traveled through the
war zone just to come back traveling
through Europe back to America it just
I'll just get emotional just looking at
the efficiency of things like how how
easy it is how that we can
um first of all in Ukraine you currently
can't fly right it's a war zone just
even the the transportation you said
roads yeah the quality of roads in the
United States is amazing just not you
know many of the places that drive in
Ukraine you're talking about I mean uh
the really bad conditions of roads and
I'm sure in many parts of Africa and
many parts of the world the world's even
worse right right and outdoor you know
having a toy indoor toilet is a is a is
a fascinatingly awesome luxury to have
it
great roads now in
parts of Africa yes yes main arteries
great Foods you're like whoa this is
moving it yes we do uh but definitely uh
more today than in my time growing up
um do we have you know
a country like Nigeria that just birthed
um six unicorns last year alone yes do
we have the African youth out there
being so amazing and you know living
their lives yes we have all of that but
it is still unfortunately
just
like we're scratching the surface yeah
and those people still are getting all
of that accomplished literally swimming
through molasses this is some of the
most
most gross
immoral unfair
waste of human capital
and so that is the started with you as a
seven-year-old asking wait a minute
how do
amazing people in Europe do this and the
amazing people in Africa don't yeah and
that's a key word amazing because that's
when I that's what I realized later
because and I it was not always like
that for me amazing and amazing right I
knew instinctively that of course we are
amazing too but so this and then the So
eventually the question became
how so I went from how can be Harvest
and we don't to the country as I'm
growing up and researching because it
stayed with me when I tell you I'm
obsessed I'm haunted I am haunted so you
can laugh all you want but it's
so the question became the question
became how come some countries like
um the United States
Singapore are rich and some others like
mine and many others in Africa are poor
that became the question
and along the line legs along the the
road I continued on living my life
wondering about this question
and I've heard all types
of reasons as to supposedly why that
might be the case
some people with a very straight face
are still pedaling the IQ Fury
According to which come on darling it's
not your fault
you know your skin color goes with a
gene sequence that just doesn't allow
you to be as smart as white people are
and it's not your fault but just accept
it bad stuff is still out there it's
very real
and I have to hear it
and others would say to me oh it's just
because you know you guys don't have an
adequate level of um
education and I say you know maybe you
got to go say that
to most of the street sellers you go see
in Senegal you go up to any of these to
many of these Street sellers in Senegal
they are wading through cars in moving
cars under the hot sun
fumes thrown at their face
trying to sell you anything and any that
you think you might be able to use
whoever we're talking about
um an ironing board
to an umbrella two Q-tips to
um you know teeth toothpicks selling you
whatever you need from from your car
Visa Street Sellers and you ask them
dear
do you have any degree yeah
I I have this great degree in math or in
in a literature or whatever some very
very educated people yet they're right
there this is what they're doing so
that's just that scale wasted human
potential
thank you so that has to do the waste
the human potential has to do now with
the system was something about the laws
yeah something some something about sort
of uh the things that limit or enable
the entrepreneur yes
because at that point I've heard this
you know I heard people say yeah your IQ
is no good
no you're not you don't have enough
degrees or you're not educated no some
people would even say it's because you
guys are malnourished you're
malnourished you need to be fed others
oh well maybe I'll give you some shoes
and maybe Something's Gonna Change
whatever and then so I heard all of this
nonsense Lex but you guess what but
guess what none of them made sense you
know why it didn't make sense because if
any of that crap was true
why oh why is it that
my parents or any other people from
these places and oh and by the way some
people call up those places God forsaken
land that's also a type of
the credit you always have to hear when
it's not just flat out
s-h-i-t whole countries from you know
one person a few years ago president of
this country
that sentiment is sometimes there it is
it it is as I go on with my life trying
to and trying to find the answer to why
are some countries like mine poor While
others are rich I'm hearing all of these
reasons thrown at me
and then they make no sense because when
how come then if my parents
move as it is usually anyone else who
moves from a poorer Nation to a nation I
suppose it is rich
all of a sudden they get to manifest the
greatest potential
so I'm starting to think this has
nothing to do with a person per se
because we're talking about the same
person same background so maybe even
same name features everything yeah now
I'm starting to think maybe it doesn't
have to do with a person maybe we're
talking about something that has to do
with a place that they came from or the
place that they're going to
so this this little thing is starting to
be in my mind again remember this is not
something that I woke up to overnight
I'm like well I got my quest it took me
for a long time and I had to I had to to
face off to have many different
ideologies face each other I had to
really have a reckoning literally in my
heart and in my mind
and so so then that's what I'm thinking
it cannot be it cannot no no no it's
just the same people it has to be about
the place but then what about this place
but then even about the place
you're thinking
again two countries different background
same outcome same background different
outcome
what is this and then I go on
I start I come I I am in Silicon Valley
in the late
um uh 90s early 2000s
that can boom all of that and
um I'm starting to discover this concept
of this thing called entrepreneurship
you know I'm in Silicon Valley and uh
just getting to experience what um seems
so cliche by now but you know people on
the getting together in the back of a
napkin talking about an idea you know
bring it out and then they go out and
they talk to someone to summon investors
who's going to invest in it then they
have a lawyers who get to you know put a
lot of this stuff together and then they
have a big four CPA firms this whole
ecosystem of what they call of
Entrepreneurship and then eventually
this concept of Entrepreneurship being
this uh this idea of um you know
creating something out of nothing so
there I am and at some point I become an
entrepreneur myself and the way I became
an entrepreneur was not like I woke up
and I'm like
I want to make money so I'm going to
become an entrepreneur you know like No
And this is also another problem I have
with people who have a problem with
entrepreneurs or business people
most entrepreneurs do not start a
business to become rich most
entrepreneurs start a business because
they have found identified a problem
that bothered them enough that they said
enough is enough I'm gonna do something
about it what entrepreneurs are are
people who criticize by creating do they
always get it right no as a matter of
fact the failure in entrepreneurship is
humongous it's it's it's Kamikaze path
to take the entrepreneurship path we
lose our spouses my first husband passed
away as soon as I was about to sign my
first term sheet and yet I had to keep
going
what force can keep you going after you
just loved Lust For love of your life
what force keeps you going the force of
oh I just want to be rich really
when your whole your whole world is
upside down
your whole world is upside down and you
just want to quit you just want to go
meet him and join him in death
I said why because of the same reason
why I started my company
I stayed because the women whom I had
put back to work by then we're talking
about some of the most vulnerable women
in my country these are women who grow
the Hibiscus which we need to make the
bisap which is the juice of taronga
remember this is our national identity
drink
and for the longest time women grow this
hibiscus that we use for the national
drink for the this drink and now that
Coca-Cola Pepsi and all that had made it
through the marketing but it is more
cool to drink those beverages now there
is no more market for the Hibiscus and
with that goes the livelihoods of these
women
and for me that bothered me enough
because in that Force I saw two things
one was a part of my culture we're
talking about I mean my part of my
cultural identity for Christ's sake
the juice of taranga you asked me what
defines you I said taranga there's a
juice for it so my culture is
disappearing and at the same time
these women
are sliding into abject poverty because
what they used to make no one needs
anymore
so that is what got me
start a company
and the company was created just because
of that I wanted to build a company that
would allow me to not only preserve this
very important aspect of my cultural
identity
and at the same time put these women
back to work and maybe it's more
difficult to put into words but there's
a kind of
it's a basic human Spirit where you see
the the place where you came from
breaking apart in some kind of way and
you have the entrepreneurial fire that
dreams of helping yes and that sometimes
it's hard to convert that into words you
have to tell nice stories and so on but
it's the basic human desire to help yes
and uh especially when you criticized by
creating especially when you've been
especially when and let's face it
um do we all are we all a bundle of
circumstances some happy some some worse
yes we are and um oftentimes I ask
myself my God why you why did you why
did you get
to have the opportunities that you have
what makes you different from if let's
say even your cousin that couldn't that
is still home yeah trapped
because we call our self-trapped
citizens when he's trapped in these
countries that go nowhere you're we're
like a bunch of Trapped citizens
so
so you see likes
when my husband passed away and I wanted
nothing more to do than to quit and to
send investors had already said we
understand if you want to stop
whatever you decide to do we'll do that
and I wanted to quit and I was actually
on my way I was in Senegal for a month
trying to really get a bearing over
myself
and
um by the end of a month I had decided
I'm Letting Go there's no way if a pain
was too great
um nothing made sense anymore it was too
much
so I went to see this woman
and I talked to the one who you know
we're talking back then
they were 400 of them later on we grew
to nine thousand
and um I told the representative of all
of them and I told her this is really
this very old lady and just looking at
her
I knew I was going through some pain but
this woman has probably gone through 10
times not that pain is calc you know
like measurable but you could tell this
woman probably lost a child as often
times happen in places you know but our
lower income countries
probably lost a husband also probably
who knows so many people lost this part
of our Lives you could see the pain you
can see the pain yet she's so so
dignified she's so dignified
and that already kind of made me like my
God stop crying but and I told and I
told her that I was quitting
I could not look her into the eyes and
um
and she said look at me
I could not look on this she said look
at me child
and I looked at her
and she said
you know
I know you're in pain but where your
husband is where your beloved is it's
absolutely nothing that you can do for
him but for us you can change everything
and I went back
so
that's what entrepreneurs are
at their best so she helped you find
your strength yes and I I I was I was
weak still but I said you put that aside
there's a job to do here
and I went back and Lex I fought with
everything that I had and this company
that I started in my kitchen
became this company that had the who's
who of the Beverage World
with at some point Roger and Rico the
chairman of PepsiCo sitting on my on my
board on my board
yeah I went back because of that so the
reason why I tell this story for me is
important
because I it the world needs to
understand
that they're so that there is a much
more there's a viable way
of caring
and of
um
being part of a solution
for
the Lesser fortunate
in terms of not keeping them where they
are and we're like the savior is coming
and you know giving them food and all
that no no no no but it's like just like
the leg up I got in my life give
somebody else a leg up